llegó el momento de repasar los
titulares de la prensa internacional con
rosa pérez masdéu rosa bienvenida buena
mañana de martes para ti vamos a hablar
de la prensa en nicaragua facebook
eliminó el eliminó una granja de troles
administrada por el frente sandinista de
liberación nacional esto es desde el
core eso es raúl como comenta la prensa
de nicaragua y otros medios facebook
anunció ayer por la noche que había
desmantelado no esta granja de trolls
que ha bueno una granja de trolls como
ya va siendo común en el lenguaje
corriente son estas automatizaciones de
publicaciones en las redes sociales en
este caso según señala facebook para
favorecer la opinión pública a favor del
gobierno de ortega y pues atacar digamos
la oposición y según comienza de la
compañía de marcas ya kerber esta
fábrica o estaría operando desde 2018
cuando tuvieron lugar las masivas
manifestaciones contra el gobierno y
habría sido desmantelada el mes y según
comunica facebook en este texto en que
explicaba esta operación se trata de las
operaciones de troles más
intergubernamentales que hemos
interrumpido hasta la fecha con varias
entidades estatales participando a la
vez y es que según señala la compañía
que ahora se llama meta como venimos
anunciando pues estaría incluida en este
entramado desde la corte suprema hasta
el instituto de telecomunicaciones
telcor hasta el propio gobierno rosa
seguimos hablando de nicaragua pero a
través de un artículo de un medio
español estamos hablando de info libre
dice deforestación la otra crisis
olvidada en nicaragua cinco periodistas
son los que hacen este artículo rosa eso
es y es que precisamente este artículo
se basa en la filtración de miles de
documentos saqueados por anónimos y
analizados por una organización que
investiga la corrupción y el crimen a
través pues esto de análisis
periodísticos y precisamente lo que
señala este texto es que nicaragua es el
país con mayor tasa de deforestación del
mundo y que esta deforestación está
directamente relacionada con un
entramado de corrupción que va desde el
propio gobierno desde la familia
presidencial hasta los gobernadores
regionales y locales y esta corrupción
implica desde la acaparación ilegal de
tierras indígenas hasta la explotación
ilegal también de tierras para la
agroindustria la industria ganadera la
minería o la industria de la madera y
precisamente señala también la
desviación de fondos internacionales
entre otras cosas y crítica que la
opinión internacional no la unión
europea o estados unidos se meta tanto
con la cuestión en política en nicaragua
pero se fije poco en el impacto
ambiental de este gobierno deja curioso
rosa porque justamente hoy se abordó
está este problema de la deforestación
al competir 6 como lo veníamos
adelantando con este corresponsal en
glasgow nuestra enviada especial louis
se ha pulido pero no debemos decir un
lado y vamos ahora a ver un medio
hermano y como info libre el francés
mediapart
eso es y es que precisamente media parte
está hermanado con info libre con este
medio que hablaba de la deforestación en
nicaragua y info libre lo que cuestiona
son las prioridades políticas del
presidente francés porque dice que si
bien macrón está dando grandes discursos
y instando a los líderes internacionales
a que actúen de forma más contundente
para frenar el cambio climático de
puertas hacia adentro si su prioridad es
mantener la potencia del nuclear francés
por encima de la lucha contra el cambio
climático y porque dice esto es una
cuestión compleja que vamos a intentar
explicar de forma sencilla se trata de
una filtración de dos páginas de un
documento interno de la comisión europea
que salió a la luz a finales de octubre
y en el que se insta a la comisión
europea precisamente a clasificar la
energía fósil del gas y la energía
nuclear como energías verdes de
transición precisamente está la comisión
europea de momento no clasifica estas
energías como energías verdes de
transición por razones que pueden
parecer obvias porque la comunidad
científica lleva tiempo insistiendo en
que hay que dejar de lado sobre todo el
gas pero pues sabemos que francia es una
potencia mundial en términos del nuclear
y a pesar de que este documento no esté
firmado porque como comentábamos solo
son dos páginas hay un pequeño error
ortográfico que ha delatado que francia
podría estar detrás de esta iniciativa
porque está gas escrito a la francesa
con una zeta y porque muchos testigos
citan que los funcionaros franceses se
están uniendo con los de polonia y los
de hungría para que estos países apoyen
el nuclear francés a cambio de que
francia apoye el gas bueno una
explicación extensa explica en pocos
segundos minutos rosa vamos a terminar
en francia liberación onda de choque
pero criminalidad en la iglesia
traumatizada los católicos franceses
reclaman reformas el artículo de
violette bule eso es este artículo pues
hace un poco de flashback a lo que vino
el impacto que tuvo este informe sobre
la pederastia en el seno de la iglesia
católica francesa que recordemos un
informe que salió a principios de
octubre y que determinó que más de
300.000 menores habían sido víctimas de
agresiones sexuales por personas
relacionadas con la iglesia católica
desde 1950 y según señala este texto en
las distintas comunidades católicas de
francia se está debatiendo lo que
debería hacerse para reaccionar a estas
informaciones y que si bien hay ciertos
fieles que están en la negación la
mayoría piden diálogo y sobre todo
responsabilidades a la jerarquía rosa
gracias por toda esta información es de
un mañana con más revista de prensa aquí
en directo américa muy buen día